chers amis républicains bonjour et bravo
bravo à l'organisation parce qu'il n'y a
vraiment que vous qui pouvez faire une
telle organisation
c'est à dire permet à un centriste
et pas n'importe quel centre y ce qu'il
a traversé la mer rouge d'accueillir
nicolas sarkozy et j'en suis très
heureux en tout premier lieu je tiens à
vous saluer vous les militants vous les
militants qui est c'est vrai et c'est
vrai dans tous les partis
dans le mien comme ailleurs rarement
remercié par votre engagement dévouée et
désintéressée
vous êtes celles et ceux qui font vivre
la démocratie du fond du coeur
merci à vous les militants après après
avoir traversé la mer rouge pour
rejoindre la famille centriste
mes rencontres successives avec de
grands hommes et je veux en cet instant
où vous êtes réunis les républicains
avoir une pensée émue pour philippe
séguin et je veux aussi saluer
et je veux saluer aussi un grand homme
d'état
je sais si mes renseignements généraux
sont bons qui sera là cet après midi je
veux parler de charles pasqua avec qui
j'ai eu l'honneur de travailler dans les
hauts-de-seine et où nous avons ensemble
mis en france le premier plan
départemental pour les quartiers
sensibles quel visionnaire
j'embrasse chaleureusement charles
pasqua
pourquoi ai-je salué philippe séguin et
charles pasqua
car je pense de toutes mes fibres que si
le peuple a besoin d'homme d'état
l'état lui a besoin d'homme du peuple
dans les pas de mon ami jean louis
borloo en 2010 ministre de la ville en
charge du grand paris
j'ai constaté à quel point cher nicolas
ta vision était juste et juste faire de
paris et de l'île de france une région
capitale plus fort pour une france plus
dynamique en europe et dans le monde
malheureusement malheureusement depuis
avec monsieur moix président notre pays
on a ça doit arriver en direct à
l'elysée depuis - monsieur président
notre pays navigue sans cap sans méthode
est donc sans résultat alors que la
direction du parti socialiste flatte les
communautés réduisant de fait la
république à la somme des intérêts
particuliers
nous nous devons redonner à chacun sa
place dans la république en proposant un
destin partagé à tous nos concitoyens
avec mon ami hervé morin philippe vigier
et les bâtisseurs de l'ue dei
je vous apporte à chaleureux et amical
salut
notre vision est celle du socle du large
rassemblement que nous devons construire
ensemble républicain et centristes avec
hervé morin philippe vigier les
bâtisseurs de lui dit
nous appelons solennellement à l'unité
de notre famille politique
une unité c'est vrai qui n'est pas
l'uniformité
l'unité c'est la condition de notre
retour aux responsabilités pour réparer
la france après trois années de
renoncement et de régression dans notre
pacte républicain
chers amis la victoire est au rendez
vous chaque fois que nous savons nous
rassembler pour unir nos forces et
d'ailleurs cela tombe bien car c'est
justement ce qu'attendent de nous nos
électeurs voyez les élections
municipales
voyez les élections départementales mes
chers amis les français attendent de
nous que nous leur proposions une aussi
belle dynamique unitaire dans chacune de
nos treize régions
voilà pourquoi j'appelle solennellement
à l'union et au rassemblement dès le
premier tour des élections régionales
ici en ile-de-france avec valérie
pécresse
partout ailleurs en france message
adressé à chantal jouanno et à d'autres
cette dynamique de l'union doit aussi se
retrouver pour la primaire qui nous
conduire à la présidentielle de 2017
oui lui dei doit participer à la
primaire mais je le dis à chacun d'entre
vous comme je le dis à mes amis de
l'udps et y est à toi nicolas lui dit
doit être partie prenante de
l'organisation et de la préparation de
la primaire à part entière en véritable
partenaire des républicains mes chers
amis je termine mes chers amis c'est
lorsque l'on est fort que l'on s'ouvre
bien entendu et je conclus pour assurer
l'organisation quelques centristes
sauteront sur leur chaise comme un cabri
en disant indépendance indépendance
à cela je dis tout aussi clairement le
centrisme ce n'est pas l'égocentrisme
et particulièrement particulièrement
dans une période où le front national
atteint un niveau sans précédent dans
notre pays
chers amis la république a besoin de
nous travaillons à remettre la france et
l'europe en marche
mettons nous en mouvement soyons unis
faisons des deux années à venir
une marche puissante et conquérante vers
la victoire pour le peuple de france